it's really exciting oh it's exciting
all right
brad pitt totally shocked fans when he
stepped out with
german model nicole polterowski earlier
this week in france
now a source tells et that their lover's
getaway was
even news to some of their nearest and
dearest
the source explains that the two were
introduced by friends
and when they first started dating they
didn't tell anyone
quote even some of their inner circle of
friends are only finding out now
the source adds that brad who split from
angelina in 2016
has been very private about dating quote
now more than ever
he doesn't want to rock the boat with
angelina he has been working so hard on
making his co-parenting run smoothly
you know we want to make it a family
fair according to et source the 56 year
old actor and the 27 year old have a lot
in common
and get along really well quote her
friends describe her as
super easy going she is very down to
earth and far from starstruck which has
been really nice for brad
brad and nicole arrived in paris france
on wednesday
an eyewitness told et that nicole flew
in from berlin
and was seen waiting at the airport for
brad to arrive from the u.s
from there they went to another airport
and boarded a private jet
bound for the south of france i'm pretty
grateful for that
and while the pair's meet-up definitely
caught fans attention
brad and nicole have actually been
hanging out since at least
last november where the two were snapped
sitting side by side during kanye west
concert at the hollywood bowl
i think he's doing something really
special there it's just it's pure
celebration
of life and people and
it's really delightful it really is
nicole who has a young son has hinted
about being in a relationship
on instagram while brad has been dodging
romance rumors since his split from
angelina
last december he opened up to the new
york times about all the gossip
surrounding his dating life since his
split from angie
explaining quote i don't know how many
women they've said i've been dating the
last two or three years
and none of it's true i'm blissfully
naive and i'm going to stay that way